the movie is set in the quiet mining
town of prosperity Arizona where life
seems to be pretty normal almost all the
people rely on mining as the city is
known for having precious gold the scene
then cuts to a truck which is carrying a
large amount of chemicals since it is
very dark the driver doesn't notice a
rabbit standing in the middle of the
road when he takes a sharp turn to avoid
it one of the toxic barrels rolls out of
the truck and falls into a nearby Pond
the next morning a spider enthusi named
Josh is seen collecting crickets from
the same Pond he is completely unaware
that the water has been polluted he
comes here every day to find insects
which will serve as food for his spiders
the movie then skips to a week later and
we are introduced to our protagonist an
11-year-old boy named Mike he is also an
avid spider Enthusiast which is why he
keeps visiting his best friend Josh that
day Mike notices that the spiders have
grown exponentially larger in size this
puzzles him so he asks asks Josh about
what he's been feeding them the latter
replies that he found some magic
crickets which serve as steroids for the
spiders Josh also believes that he is
going to make a fortune out of his new
discovery as the two continue discussing
the strange phenomenon a dangerous
tarantula gets out of its enclosure Josh
then shows Mike a large orb weaver
spider which he has named Consuela it
appears to be extremely poisonous and
deadly after a while Mike's alarm rings
and he says that he has to go to school
he then leaves the place but not before
promising to return the following
weekend once the boy is gone it finally
Dawns on Josh that one of his tarantulas
is missing he desperately begins looking
for it but the tarantula finds him first
and bites him on his back Josh screams
in horror as the pain is unbearable but
there is no one to help him out to make
matters worse he ends up knocking over
the other enclosures releasing all the
spiders in the process at last Josh
meets a gruesome end when the mutated
insects swarm him and dissect him bit by
bit the following week Mike is headed
towards his best friend's house when he
is stopped by the town's Sheriff she is
none other than his mom Samantha Mike
who is unaware that his friend is Dad
insists that he pay a short visit but
Samantha orders that he go home
immediately she claims that the nearby
Pond has been contaminated so the area
is not safe currently she and her
colleague Pete are trying to identify
the harmful chemical that has been
polluting the pond at night Mike grows
really worried about his friend Josh
since the two haven't talked in over a
week he tries to call him but of course
there is no one to receive it we are
then taken to Josh's residence which has
been completely taken over by the
spiders the entire place is covered in
cobwebs and the spiders have grown to
become the size of dogs meanwhile at the
local mall the town's mayor is making an
announcement he says that the minds have
become too old and outdated so they
should build a commercial complex there
he now wants the people to sell their
land so that this can be made possible
however most of the people voed their
disagreement right away among them is
Chris the son of a mine worker who
recently passed away he comes forward
and asserts that he is never going to
sell his land the mayor tries to insult
him but Chris retaliates by punching him
in the face Chris is the hero we all
want to be fortunately before the
situation can escalate Samantha arrives
there and separates them she then takes
Chris away and warns him to be more
sensible next time as their conversation
unfolds we learn that they share a
romantic history they are still in love
with each other but are too afraid to
express it however the very next morning
Chris shows up at her place with a
bouquet of flowers he straight away
expresses his love for her and asks her
out on a date Samantha doesn't respond
to the proposal but she agrees for the
date meanwhile as the two are engaged in
conversation Mike sneaks out of the
house he goes straight to Josh's Farm
which has been completely over run by
the insects Mike slowly makes his way
inside and is horrified to witness its
state the spiders are already gone but
they have left enormous footprints on
the ground indicating that they have
doubled in size after a while as Mike is
exploring the area he spots a massive
spider coming out of a cave this freaks
him out so he immediately makes a run
for it once he reaches the road he is
spotted by Chris who happens to be
returning home he gives the boy a ride
and asks where he's going Mike brings
out a large ter anula leg and claims
that the spiders have gone Rogue he
describes that one of them was the size
of a rhino however Chris believes that
the boy is joking so he simply laughs at
this after returning home Mike
desperately tries to explain the entire
scenario to his mom hoping that she out
of all people will believe him however
she instead gets angry saying that he is
watching too much television these days
meanwhile the spiders begin their
attacks in different parts of the city
at Pete's house his pet cat is devoured
by a large spider similarly in the
underground mine when a man finds that
the water pipes are jammed he decides to
blow it with his mouth as soon as he
does so his expression changes and a
large number of deadly spiders crawl out
of his mouth then the Queen Spider
Consuela lunges at him from behind and
finishes him off in another incident the
mayor's ostriches are brutally dissected
by the creatures as the days pass the
town's people realize that they are
being attacked by something but they
have no clue that it's a bunch of
eight-legged insects however that all
changes when one day the spiders finally
decide to show themselves as the mayor's
son JN and his friends are hanging out
they suddenly show up and begin their
Onslaught the remaining boys quickly get
on their bikes to escape but most of
them are caught by the insanely fast
monsters only Jon manages to get away
unharmed as he cleverly guides the
spiders towards a speeding oil truck
resulting in an explosion that kills
them at night Chris's mom is preparing
some food in the kitchen when she
realizes that her dog is missing as she
looks for it she finds a trail of blood
that leads her to a nearby mine turns
out the house is connected to the mine
and only a small layer was separating it
now that layer has been torn apart
possibly by the spiders worried the
woman slowly goes inside the mine and
this is when she is attacked by some
gigantic spiders they quickly
incapacitate her and wrap her in a
cocoon i' say that she'll come out as a
butterf fly but she's already smoking
hot at the same time Chris arrives home
and hears his mother's screams he rushes
to the mine but it's too late as the
monsters have already taken her away all
he finds is a large spider leg which
makes him realize that Mike was telling
the truth all along in the next scene
Chris rushes to meet the boy and the
latter finally has the chance to
Showcase his knowledge of spiders he
theorizes that the chemicals have made
the insects exponentially larger and
they will keep growing as long long as
they have the toxins in their bodies he
also reassures Chris that his mom is not
dead as the orb weavers generally wrap
their prey in cocoons but do not kill
them this is because they want to
impress the Queen by offering her food
Samantha who is listening to all this is
left completely speechless just then
Mike's sister starts screaming in the
other room and when they all Rush inside
they find a spider trying to wrap its
web around her Chris tries to intervene
but he ends up being incapacitated as
well luckily this buys Samantha enough
time to pick up her gun and shoot that
insect dead after this she tries to call
for backup but all the phone lines
appear to be dead left with no choice
she uses her walkie-talkie to call her
assistant Todd the latter is very much
aware of the situation and He suggests
that they use the local radio station to
alert the public shortly after the group
arrives at the radio station which is
being operated by a guy named harlon
Samantha quickly goes live and warns all
the people that they being attacked by
giant insects she requests all of them
to run towards the local mall as it is
the only safe place right now however
the people completely ignore her pleas
thinking that she's joking this is
because the owner of the radio station
harlon is always high and makes
insensitive jokes meanwhile a large
tarantula is passing by the radio
station when it senses that there are
people inside it quickly launches an
attack Samantha and the group are now
stuck and it appears as if they're going
to be killed but fortunately Todd and
the others arrive in time to rescue them
after this the group heads towards the
mall at this point the city has been
completely overrun by the giant spiders
they are killing people at an alarming
rate causing complete chaos meanwhile a
large number of people have gathered
inside the local mall Samantha and her
group also arrive but so do the spiders
the creatures have become so aggressive
that they are killing humans with a
single strike fearing that the situation
may go out of hand Samantha Chris and
and a few others decide to confront them
using guns however there's too many
spiders to take care of Todd then comes
up with a plan he says that the only way
to save the city is by summoning the
Army however Samantha says that it's
impossible because all the phone lines
are dead this means that they are
totally disconnected from the rest of
the country luckily the mayor has a
mobile phone which was a rare luxury
back in these days due to the ongoing
chaos the network is a bit weak but he
is sure that if they climb the nearby
Tower they can make make the call the
mission appears to be a dangerous one
but it is the only chance they have
right now so Chris and Harland decide to
head to the Terrace before leaving Mike
gives Chris a perfume explaining that
the spiders have very weak eyesight so
they rely on their smell if this perfume
is spray on them they can be rendered
senseless for a few seconds Chris thanks
the boy for the information and then
departs after a while the duo reaches
the Terrace and Chris decides to make
the climb while harlon keeps guard the
phone eventually gets a signal and Chris
is is able to make a call however when
he tries to explain the situation the
Army Personnel doesn't believe him and
cuts the call everyone in this movie is
reverse gaslighting themselves at the
same time a swarm of spiders arrives at
the place in a swift move Harland lures
them towards himself and then jumps from
the Terrace he manages to survive the
fall and Chris also uses the distraction
to make a run for it meanwhile the queen
tarantula consua manages to destroy the
mall's gate allowing the other spiders
to enter this creates chaos among the
people as several of them are laid to
death immediately it's almost like
collecting every single person in town
in one place was a really stupid idea
when the situation escalates Samantha
gathers the survivors and urges them to
enter the nearby mine soon Chris also
joins them and the group realizes that
the mine is filled with methane this
means the entire place can explode with
even a small spark of fire as the group
Ventures forward they realize that they
have actually entered the spider's
hideout this becomes even more evident
when they find several cocooned humans
hung on the ceiling most of them appear
to be alive but time is running out as
the queen will be feasting on them soon
when Chris finds the mayor inside of one
of the cocoons hope fills his heart as
he believes that his mom is still alive
too he then asks Samantha to lead the
group in another Direction while he goes
looking for his mom before they separate
the two confess their love for one
another and decide to get married once
the chaos ends Chris also asks Samantha
to light up the generator powering the
mine as he has a plan in mind after this
he grabs a motorbike and slowly walks
inside the dark tunnel he eventually
finds his mom who turns out to be alive
but unfortunately before they can get
away Consuela arrives at the scene
angrier than ever Chris tries to shoot
at it but then he realizes that if he
does so the entire place will explode so
as a last resort he brings out the
perfume given to him by Mike and sprays
it toward the monster surprisingly the
plan works work as consel is rendered
immobile for a few seconds taking
advantage of this opportunity Chris gets
on the bike with his mom and speeds away
from there along the way he places a
matchbox in one of the light bulbs at
the same time Samantha and the group
manage to exit the mine she also finds
the generator and Powers it as soon as
she does so the match sticks ignite and
a large explosion occurs inside the mine
curs and his mom barely make it out in
the last second but the poor spiders are
not so lucky every sing single one of
them is torched inside the mine finally
bringing an end to this
madness subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching